[Music]
so thanks for having me um I presented
uh let's say a related Topic at a
different P Pata Meetup uh and I
actually don't want to talk about the
same thing so I'm talking about a
different thing now so that's indeed
about Django and JPC and how we use that
for automated visual inspection maybe
first a slide about me so I was already
introduced I'm a system architect I
worked for uh I think over nine years
already at prodev Technologies I've
worked uh in the beginning more as a
software architect on our Industrial
Automation platform so prodev is an uh
company that manufactures designs and
manufactur electronics and we also
automate that manufacturing so I worked
a lot with robotic automation basically
um but more recently I'm working on all
kind of AI and machine learning systems
and I'm also the competence owner of
that to share the knowledge basically to
people who do not know about AI nml yet
or um yeah some experts just to sit
together and uh review interesting
papers
uh yeah and I'm also a drummer and I
like hiking just mother hobes but that's
not what I'm here to talk about I'm here
to talk about uh Python and how we use
ajango and GPC so I'll first introduce
what is meant with automatic visual
inspection uh I also will introduce the
term mlops and I actually want to see uh
people who have you have heard of the
term but are you actually using it are
the people like applying mlops in their
company see some hands like are you an
ml engineer for instance then you're
doing ml Ops right okay
um so I'll talk a bit about the Proto AI
framework which is a software framework
we built to support this melops process
I'll give an introduction to Jango and
grpc as well and we'll end with a
demonstration uh I was asked to record
them so we know that they will work uh
at the P data Meetup I had to come back
and make it work uh it did work in the
end was an internet connection but now
if the movies work it will uh show you
the demo um and I also want to know who
of you have been using Jango are using
Jango not very much that's okay that's
good and
JPC expect even less yeah just a few
hands yeah because JPC obviously is not
something python specific right it's
something you can use it's an interface
uh and you can use it with a lot of
other languages but I'm just going to
show you an example here okay so give
you a bit of a scope of what we mean
with automatic visual inspection so
these are some Pro Drive products prove
is an electronics company we design and
manufacture all these kind of products
so here in uh in the north of einthoven
in son actually uh we manufacture a lot
of these um it can be an automotive
wallbox to charge your Electro
electrical car to uh an air uh quality
sensor that's an automotive product so
it measures the quality in your car and
outside um linear actuator so it's very
broad uh portfolio of all kind of let's
say big products let's say small sensors
the size of this clicker um and well we
want to manufacture high quality
products so we would have to we'll have
to inspect them just to put down some
requirements on this automated visual
inspection obviously ly we want to have
no false negatives we don't want to miss
any defect because if we miss it our
customers receive broken products we get
a bad bad rep and we have to repair them
surf it is very expensive um and ideally
we also uh minimize the false positives
because otherwise our algorithms or this
this this visual inspection algorithms
constantly triggering hey there's a
defect hey there's a defect and people
will just start clicking yes no fine
it's pass and click and start ignoring
the inspection um yeah there there's no
perfect world we have to put some
numbers on this we put 0.1 false
positive rate 1% there 0.1% is 1 in a,
basically um there are some more
requirements uh we manufacture thousands
of different products I just showed you
a few but we have many many more all
kind of different variants ideally we
have no competences to add and create
these new visual inspections because
yeah creating them for all these
products by Engineers is also very
expensive so we want people in the
factory to do that um and we have
different uh setups in our Factory with
uh camera setups close to window in a
space where there's almost no light so
we have to deal with all these
environmental variations and just some
examples of these inspections and there
are some variants of this but these are
let's say the main classes so we have
our presence uh detection is a component
there or not so you see this example
there's uh there's supposed to be five
cables here here there's a cable missing
and here you see a screw screw is
missing here other category would be
alignment so again the cable is here now
but and here as well but it's not fully
in so it's misaligned and then we have
this let's say third category weall
damage can be anything so you see a line
of uh there's actually glue line so
there's a part here there's a defect or
you can have a text marking where
something missing these are basically
the classes we would have to deal with
um and I mentioned yeah we want to have
lighting invariant it should be easy to
train no computer vision uh expertise
required well you might end up hey
that's like a very good uh problem
statement for a deep learning problem
well let's try that right let's go ahead
so you take your your file storage in
our case a few years ago when we started
this all our images were on the network
drive um yeah that should be good enough
right well no it we don't want to start
in supervise we want to have a
supervised problem so we need to label
them so here you can see indeed these
images have been marked green means pass
red means fill okay and now now we can
start so you give these images to your
to your data scientist or uh your ml
engineer depending on what that role is
in that point they make a nice model in
their Jupiter notebook they use their
favorite Library pie torch carot
whatever they like maybe even a
combination of two doesn't really matter
they make the perfect make the perfect
model and they say well this is the
performance it meets the the things I
just said in the previous slides and
then there this border chug it over to
the software engineer that has to
integrate it in the camera setup well
that has no idea how to interpret the
model do I need to or I need to crop
images I need to uh normalize them uh do
I need to monitor the model will it keep
on performing and doing its job over
time well these are all things that are
not considered in general and at some
point the model will fail uh this is
obviously something you have to deal
with um I normally also show Show a
slide with many many other Frameworks
that we can use but I'll I'll limit just
to uh the things I'm going to discuss
now Jango and JPC but there's a process
that can help you uh solve this and
that's basically the mlops process and I
guess when you're also a software
developer you're very well aware of the
devops process which is development and
operations where you version your code
you add uh versions to the releases you
have continuous integration with tests
unit tests uh different uh production
staging and production environment to
test everything
um and with machine learning it's
actually the same but just with some
extra Cycles so you also add a machine
learning cycle where you train your
model you uh see uh what architecture
was used what parameters uh where you
give a version to your model and for the
data it holds the same you combine all
the data uh you you label your data but
you also register um where it is from
who labeled it and which data set you
use to actually train the model and when
you have all these Loops under control
then you know you have a robust machine
learning application because then you
can guarantee well not guarantee but you
can at least Trace where the problem
could be and you can try to improve and
we had this example where for instance
somebody did not uh mention which data
was used and we had a nice very good
performance model which at some point
drifted off we wanted to improve it but
we had no idea where to start because we
didn't know what data was used so again
we had to start from
scratch um how would you apply this to
machine learning well uh sorry how would
you apply mlops to Avi I just made
really simple overview so your data in
this casee would be the images with the
data uh then you go to training where
you train your favorite deep learning
model you version and store that and
then you have your deployment setup
where uh your camera setup could send
the images to this model for instance as
a web service and then finally you have
a monitoring dashboard where you also
check if everything is performing in the
the way you expected it for instance
with some alerts and thresholds and you
use that again to gather new data label
new data and improve your model uh do
take take care that you need a human in
the loop because if you have a model
that trains on its own input you will
probably degrade over time because the
mistakes it will make it will make more
mistakes in in the end and then train on
that and it becomes one big mess so do
take uh that into
account all right um this is a big slide
and I just I don't want to detail out
all these things that we have put in our
Pro Drive AI framework but basically is
an open source a collection of Open
Source uh tools mostly python tools
almost all tools I think um that we've
let's say glued together and this is our
framework that we run on premise we can
run on premise or on our on a kubernetes
cluster in in Azure for inst that
doesn't really matter and um basically I
want to focus on this part which is
really start with the data part because
if your data is not well defined not
well structured um yeah the other parts
will become really hard to uh to get
under control and so the last talk was
about this part the the P data Meetup
about ml flow and Seldon core where you
do the deployments and I'm going to talk
about this part um and you can see that
the images from the production setup
actually arrive in in the data
management component where we have Jango
and through an GPC interface so the
camera setups can send their images over
there including potentially labels and
other
metadata um so I saw some hands um and
this is not a comprehensive overview of
what Jango does I also am not a
maintainer of D Jango just a user um but
it's indeed a web framework and they uh
you call it themselves they call it
model template view where you have uh
let's say models that Define your
database structure then you have
template files where you can use all
those the data fields of those models
and you can generate views and the view
could be a view for a user but it could
also be a view for another application
like an API uh they've been in active
development since 20 2005 so it's
already also been here for some time and
I mentioned templating but also caching
authentication uh very a lot of built-in
features one I didn't even mention you
have a very nice uh let's say uh
functional type querying so you can just
stack these things together also like
pandas and polars where you just combine
statements and it's lazy execution so
also D Jango decides okay actually I'm
going to do it in a different order and
build the most efficient SQL create for
you this is an example of the interface
that you get for free so that's their
admin interface um all the data models
that you make you can yeah add here
change and the way you want you can add
users even if you want and that's how
you can at least get started on a really
simple application and build on from
there it's not that this is just a a
nice open source package no there's a
lot of other big companies that actually
use it like insta Mozilla last bit bit
bucket was built with this as far as I
also could read on the Wikipedia so it's
it's definitely used by a lot of bigger
companies and that's the great part they
have many many plugins and extensibility
so I'm going to show you indeed the
Django GPC uh plugin and there are some
variants with their uh pros and cons but
I now selected this one just for this
demo but there are many other things out
there as well
okay but then if we want to build an
application here we do need to have some
data model for the automatic visual
inspection so I'm going to take this
image as an example so this is a a
reference image as a product and I'm
going to build the data model up here in
the center so the first thing we'll
start with we have a product that is
basically uh represented by this image
and a product could have one or more
inspection views you can have an
inspection from the top from the side
maybe inspection view view during
different stages of the man facturing
process and that's basically how we
Define it here so we have a product we
have an inspection view um we have one
or more inspection views basically
that's how we Define it here on this
inspection view uh we Define inspection
tasks and all these inspection tasks are
these let's say rectangles over here and
each rectangle indicates a certain
inspection that you would have to do on
that location on that product so we have
an uh it's a link to the view obviously
we have an
name H it's not shown here but we should
have a name oh yeah there's a name and
we have the basically the definition of
this rectangle in that image well this
is already a very nice setup to at least
Define all your inspections right we can
Define multiple products multiple views
on that product and we can Define
multiple tasks on each
view um then the other side we also want
to gather let's say samples from
production this is just a reference
sample but we're well when we're
producing we're not just building one
we're building many obviously and uh
we're going to store them as well and
Link them to this data model so we have
an I call it here an image um and
basically we can have many of them and
they're linked to this view so each
image is linked to a view and on top of
that we also want to label this so each
of these same task that you see here can
be labeled so a label is a connection
between an image uh and a task and then
basically indicating if that's pass or
fail so it could be that this region
there's a component missing or here
there's something misaligned that
depends on the task this is at least a
simple version of our dat of a data
model uh I say it's also simplified it
our data model does look like this but
it's a little more more complex but I
just simplifi it for for the demo here
um yeah so indeed the label is linked to
all these images and indicates if
they're pass or
fail uh then onto JPC so JPC indeed is
not python specific um and its acronym
is actually
a grpc remote procedure call so it's a
recursive acronym the G is not
officially Google I think it is it is
made by Google but um and um basically
what you can do that you can connect
different software microservices
together so they can allow maybe you're
familiar with like rest interfaces this
is similar but it's in my opinion a bit
more structured and well defined um yeah
and there's some nice features like B
directional streaming and cancellation
and timeouts just some so how actually
would you define such an interface and
what they how do you do that you you
have a Proto buff file it's a different
language although it's very easy to to
read and comprehend you basically say we
have this greeter service is an example
that they always use on their website
and the service has one remote procedure
calls uh say hello there's a request
here and a reply and these messages are
also defined here so you put your name
here and I think the idea is that then
the return message would be uh hello and
then your name it's just a really simple
thing but really nice is that with this
definition you can generate a service
for almost any major language so
obviously python I'm going to show here
but also C go Java and they have a
client for Julia now also very nice so
it's very uh cross uh domain for
instance where we use in the factory
some of our setups in the factory run C
and there we built the C interface and
uh let's say on our service the data
manager with jangu with python and it
all works perfectly together and the
Really key here is you have a really
well- defined interface and I I think
it's also possible with open API to
generate this but this is already part
of the protocol and this is just how it
works and it's also really fast because
it's a serialized binary
format all right then moving on uh to
the demo um so what do we actually want
to do we want to store the uh the
definition of our inspection like the
data model I just showed you what
inspection where do we do the inspection
we want to store the sample so data
coming from production and we want to
use a GPC interface to actually uh to do
that um so what we're going to do I have
it defined in four stages always first
we're going to start with our
environment uh I use poetry I want to
see are there people who are using
poetry yeah I can ask are there people
using pip then that's everybody probably
because otherwise you can't use python
but uh there's also there are a lot of
environments actually there's a talk now
ongoing on pixie which is also very nice
dependency management tool and there are
a few we we did use pipn I'm not sure if
people also use
pipn not that many okay yeah we started
with that but at some point let's say
locking our packages which is setting a
certain version of the packages took
like an hour and with poetry it was a
few minutes so and for us it was really
clear to swap to that but I'll show that
then we'll set up a Jango project and an
app we're going to Define our data model
uh the DC interface and then hopefully
send some images all right and I have a
recording here let's see if it works I
think so can start something yeah so we
start with first statement we make an
git repository get init and we make uh
with poetry also do an init which will
create our P project. toml file through
some interactive uh prompting so it asks
me to uh create a description um it asks
and to make some package I'm not going
to do that so now we have a nice initial
P project. Tomo file which describes our
package we're going into the Poetry
shell which means we're now in this
environment basically and we're going to
add some dependencies so installing
Django installing GPC all those things
we need um and it writes it in a lock
file so that's done then we also add
some development dependencies so these
are only dependencies you'll need if you
want to change this repository not when
you want to use it that's also there and
you can see now this is all added to the
PIP project. tomal file in a very nice
way now we'll start uh our Jango project
with theang Jango admin uh command so we
have a project called Avi site and in
that uh directory we create an Django
app so each Jango site can have multiple
apps and then you end up with this
structure so you see the the Avi app
over here with all its default files and
you see the site over here so the site
is really the generic thing of
configuration of D Jango uh and the site
is really the specific data models and
admin interface and views of that
specific app and as I said you can have
multiple obviously uh in the same Jango
site well look looking at some of the
code and the first step is to actually
Define your data models and I've what
you can see here I've defined um the
product which is really simple right
it's just a Char field with name and a
text field description uh the thing I
did add here is a unique is true which
means you cannot have a product with the
same name that's just an example but you
can add that to more Fields if you would
would like that and for instance the
description is blank which means you you
don't have to fill it in if there's no
uh blank or null classifier or uh at
parameter in your field it means you
have to provide it otherwise you cannot
create that object and then we have the
view here as well so same name in
description in this case uh the name is
not unique but something else will be
unique
um it's linked to the product there a
foreign key right so there's a
relationship between these two and it
has a reference image which is an image
field and that's basically that image
without the rectangles that's just the
image of the the product and we added
this so we can have this meta class
where we Define a more complex
constraint and what this actually does
want want to have a unique inspection
view name per product because it would
not make sense if you have a top view
for a product and then again have a top
view for a product and I can't put that
here right because there can be a top
view for product a but there can also be
a top view for product B so if I would
put that unique here it would not allow
me to create top view for product B so
you have to make that in a more uh
complex constraint uh yeah and you can
provide the string functions which are
really nice if you view them in the
admin interface
later uh and then we have the inspection
task well similar and we have have again
a name here it is linked to the
inspection view instead of the product
because you can have this is one to many
one product to many inspection views and
again uh one inspection view to many
tasks um so that's again that's our
foreign key here and then we have our uh
fields that describe the rectangle so
Xmen y Min width and height and they're
all positive integer fields and some
help text which really helps users in
the admin interface to describe what it
this is and we added something extra
here which is clean and with this method
uh this is something that Django can
call um it already checks if you cannot
add negative numbers now that's already
not possible in in the atmin interface
but there's something more we need to
check because you can now if you don't
have this clean function you could
create a rectangle that goes outside of
your image which doesn't make sense so
what we basically do here uh we check if
um if the rectang goes outside in the
width or in the height and if that is
the case we'll throw a validation error
which will be shown uh to the
user then okay those are our data models
and then we will Define the admin
interface Well normally you could also
only do the bottom part where you just
say uh to the to jangle basically yes
generate a uh an admin page for this
data model and I added some more that I
didn't show there's also label and image
here but they're similar to the ones I
just showed you uh but we want you can
also customize them so you can create
this custom uh inspection view admin if
you uh basically inherit from this model
admin uh part from Django and you can
add more things you have to say ah it's
for this model we have some only fields
we want to display these fields in a
list when you have the list view of all
the objects and um yeah if you the the
name of the object will be a link you
can click it and you can go to its
details and this is basically how you
could uh provide it this render
reference image and this render image
these are custom methods we put on our
uh data classes or data models um so
that we can actually view the image in
the admin interface because otherwise it
just shows you a link and you can click
it and it goes to another tab but now we
can view it in the same page so here you
again you can see the structure right so
we have uh the admin that we're showing
now and the one before that was the
model stop by so let's see how that
would work so we're going to create them
I put the The Edge next to it so you can
actually see what's going on first thing
to be note make sure you're in your
environment because otherwise it
wouldn't recognize Dango that's the
Poetry shell that I did before um and
we're going to run the manage.py command
from Jango with the command make
migrations and it will make the first
SQL migration to create the database and
when we actually call migrate it will
create that database and you see this SQ
light so by default uses site to um yeah
to storage data we have to create a
super user because otherwise we cannot
log in into the admin interface so I'll
do it here as well um and then we're
going to run it and it's basically going
to run as a local server so you see it
here you can click this link and go here
so I have to log in now with the super
user I just created and boom there you
have your admin interface and you see
it's all the models over here uh well
I'm going to actually a product so let's
say we add a test product and we want to
add an inspection view um on to that
product so we have top view we add it we
add an
image and we save it oh you see a nice
inspection image of our product you can
even see it in list view now if you want
and I zoomed in so it's really tiny now
but this is just to so you can read it
uh we're going to add an a task so the
presence of screw one um again link it
to The View now adding some
coordinates 2,000 is a bit much but you
can see yeah oh it's indeed larger and
this should be larger than the width not
the height obviously you can fix it save
it boom there it is so it's Sav now uh
we can add more we could add a an actual
image that would be captured from
production so this image is actually
similar to the one you just saw but it's
a different one and this actually has a
defect there's all kind of arrows on
that one so here actually you see the
screw is missing so we could already add
a label now and let's do that so we
select that image and that task we only
have one so now it's easy and we say no
the result is false this is a failure
and we save it it's just a really simple
example right obviously people are not
going to do it like this but this could
be your back end you could make really
nice uh interfaces on top of this uh
maybe using Solara to create a really
nice interface right and then the user
can actually use it in the factory but
that's a yeah a simple way to get
started but then about G to the JPC part
cuz I only mentioned uh the Jango part
for now but yeah why do you how do you
then create this GPC interface again we
need to start with uh this uh Proto file
that defines our interface so now it's
not the same as the greeter client now
we actually put something uh that makes
sense in there so um yeah we have a
service called image data and there's
one called called store image and again
we have a request and a response in this
case the request would be uh a uint 64
an inspection view this would be the
private key of your inspection sorry the
primary key of your inspection View and
then the btes this is the actual image
that's your payloads and what what what
the service will then return is
basically the ID of this stored object
so again the primary key all right but
then we need to how how do we convert
this to python code well there's a
package called GPC IO tools so normally
you need grpc to actually create the
service and GPC IO or so to use it and
gpci iio tools builds the python service
from this protuff code
and um this is not that generated Proto
code I can also show you that but this
is basically how you would use it so now
we're in services. pi and with this
piece of python code we can use this
interface that is generated in the back
um and well if a request comes in we
have to do something in the service
right so what we do here this request
comes in we actually first check does
this view ID that you give does it
actually exist because otherwise it
doesn't make sense right so we check if
that one exists if not we abort and the
client actually receives an error
message if it does we'll create an image
We'll add we'll link to this inspection
view We'll add the payload the bytes of
the image we'll save it and uh we'll
after saving actually generates the
primary key and we can use it in the
response that's really simple
implementation um all right and don't
forget to add the GPC server also to the
uh the settings otherwise Jango doesn't
know you've created this method
there um and what I'm going to do I have
this script where I connect to uh the
server that started and I will just send
some random images and I'll show you
basically in the demo what that will
look
like it works yeah so now the the
service is not generated this is the
prot file so I'm going to use that uh
JPC IO tools command really long command
to generate it now we have these three
files which actually contain your
service and now you see also that they
are recognized here so now this service
uh yeah and you see indeed the this this
hook you need to put that in your
settings and then D Jango basically
knows ah you've created the GPC service
and I need to uh when you turn it on I
need to sent the request over there um
so let's run the server again so we're
first going to run the normal uh let's
say HTTP server we can see what's going
on so yeah it still works we have uh a
test product we have uh a production a
view in this case it's a blue image
doesn't really matter it's just a
generated one and we have no images yet
okay well let's see if we can put them
in with our GPC service so we're going
to also start a GPC server GPC server so
you do manage GPC server now it's
running on this port same port as here
right Local Host
551 um so let's run this python script
and see what happens right because this
is the client
side and I added the the tddm so you can
see the progress well goes really fast
and boom refresh the page and there you
have all your in this case randomly
generated images and you can see there's
a time stamp so we added all kind well
that's just one type of metadata but
really in in production add way more
right where is it captured what's the
camera setup um if you make a label who
labeled it all those things you need to
do yeah so you can open the view the
view is linked to this uh the same uh
image in Cas this the blue image again
but that's just your
example all right so what would be the
next steps right um for future
considerations we didn't talk about
deployment so we have to think about
hosting a database somewhere storing the
files now it's just stored on the local
Django instance we don't have any tests
yet there is a nice test part in Django
I didn't have time to show that but it's
also there um and as I mentioned we need
to have way more validation because now
you can send an image a sample image for
instance that's way bigger than your
product view that actually happened
because they changed the camera setup at
some point so add more validation there
but also log way more things what's the
as I mentioned right what's the the
shutter speed of your camera all those
things you need to know for
reproducibility authentication should
should be added as well now uh you have
this default Django thing but we want to
connect it to our active directory for
instance uh and a labeling interface
would be really nice just going through
these tables is definitely not something
that's workable in production but again
it could be used as a back end right so
some key takeaways um and this is
basically really the point right this is
just an example but it's really clear
that if you want to do machine learning
first think about your data and try to
structure it in a way so um think indeed
can I create a model of of my problem
store that especially if it's a generic
one and um basically you need to think
how your data is stored not uh sorry you
need to think how it should be stored
how not how it is stored because people
just think this is the way it is and
this is how we need to continue but
that's that's obviously not the way you
need to go um yeah structure your data
and storage where does the data come
from I mentioned it already uh you can
standardize the format of Ingress so I
use the GPC service in that case but uh
really important thing also to do after
that if you have all these images and D
data collected combine it into a data
set uh so that if you start training you
exactly know what you've trained on and
finally I mentioned that already we made
a really simple labeling interface no
time to show it here but this is an
example where you can click basically
through these regions and click password
faill and that's how we could uh label
our inspection tasks I think that was my
final slide so according to that clock
I'm on time but uh maybe to your clock
not so thank
you not sure if there are any questions
I got I'm sitting next to you sure so so
Thomas great talk um uh lot of
information very dense right so so thank
you for speaking quickly so uh uh one of
the questions that comes to mind is like
when you have all of these different
products right you're you have to
destroy your products to train your
models can you talk a little bit about
uh do I you have to waste Break Stuff to
retrain it or how do you deal with that
maybe it's out of scope but oh know
that's an expensive operation when
you're building thousands of these
things yes guess yes yeah sometimes
hundreds of thousands even no this is a
very uh big problem it really depends on
how you would solve machine learning
right I didn't mention that now but we
currently have a lot of binary
classification models in uh production
which means you need you do need a lot
of images of bad products which might
you need to break them yourself uh you
need to pull out a cable take a picture
put it in the wrong order take a picture
make a scratch take a picture oh now the
product is broken yeah so that's very
expensive um we might have we've done
that for some of our high volume
products because there we know it pays
off but we also have lower volume
products and then we're actually not
solving it with classific traditional
binary classification now we want to use
anomaly detection so we only need images
of let's say the good products and from
that we're just going to detect
something is wrong we lose that we know
what is wrong but we least know
something is not okay and we can already
get started with this just collect
images of good products and you can
train these models and there's a lot of
libraries I think anomaly was also shown
at some of the Pata meups that you can
use for this so you really only train on
the good data and that should be enough
that's also our way forward so we still
need to collect this data and the
labeling is only relevant for when we
actually find defects so we can use them
for verification
yeah I guess people want bitter balls or
there's still
question yeah thank you for the talk um
I think rest is still way more used than
grpc what what made you decide to like
switch to grpc yeah so one of the key
things is the the really strict well
defin well-known definition with Proto
as I showed it here I think that's a
really nice feature uh is very fast and
we use it primarily internally in our
company in a lot of different places so
we can generate the interfaces we don't
need to tell them oh yeah we changed
this interface so you now have to
actually change this parameter name no
we just release a new version of our
Proto buff file which is also in a
package so we put this for C we put it
in newat package for python we put it in
a pip Python package and basically
that's how you can use it so we just
tell people hey you can can now get our
new version and you can make them
backwards compatible because you can add
fields and GPC still works with let's
say if you have an older version of that
message as long as your servers can deal
with that but that should fine should be
fine you can just add fields and there's
way of doing backers compatibility so
back compatibility is one nice uh
interface description and it's really
fast because it's binary so also for a
lot of messages it will be it will pay
off in the end because it's faster than
rest
yeah
so thanks so much for giving us the
importance of collecting data and
labeling it correctly so I would like to
give a huge round of applause to Thomas
again
[Applause]
[Music]
for